[Applause]
the verdict was swift and decisive
the case that became a national
referendum on racial justice still held
the power to surprise
guilty guilty guilty this verdict a jury
found former minneapolis police officer
derrick chauvin guilty in the racially
charged killing of george floyd
on all counts second degree murder third
degree murder
and second degree manslaughter today
you have the cameras all around the
world
to see and show what happened to my
brother
it was a motion picture the world seeing
his life being extinguished
and i could do nothing but watch
especially in that courtroom
over and over and over again as my
brother was murdered
there's no comparison i can't even
that's just i mean there's no words i
can't even compare
that to this because we got justice
we got just as we want okay
we won he may not be here
but we won it was chauvin
expressionless in court who was on trial
but it was floyd who became a symbol of
racial justice for black americans who
felt
targeted and abused by police for
generations
we always maintained the moral high
ground
knowing that we were on the right side
of history
the verdict resonated in the white house
where president joe biden
called floyd's family we hadn't seen
since the civil rights year in the 60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough enough of the senseless killings
today today's verdict is
a step forward the legal system had to
operate behind barricades manned by
national guard troops
in a city that boarded up businesses and
closed its schools
in anticipation of a ruling that ended
months of demonstrations
with celebration the case that began
with a fake
twenty dollar bill and ended with a
nationwide movement
might have gone unnoticed if it hadn't
been for a viral video taken by a
seventeen-year-old girl
as excruciating to watch as it was to
re-watch
over and over again throughout the trial
of a man treated without dignity
speaking his final words
crowds have manned the streets of
minneapolis and the nation since floyd
died on may 25th
as they leave the courthouse square they
insist the movement
will continue john hendren al jazeera
minneapolis